le problème alors je vais vous raconter
une histoire parce que j'y lis tout ce
soir at le problème non mais t'inquiète
pas non après semaine de malik bentalha
c'est que quand il est sur une meuf
il veut que y est tous ses potes qui
viennent avec lui la compagnie pression
qui t'appelle à le soir c'est vrai est
ce que tu peux venir
il ya franck gastambide ayane et dit je
suis sur un dos une meuf mais je veux
que vous la voyez avant par exemple
besoin de l'aval des copains des copains
alors pas voulu que serré donc on est
obligé d'aller avec lui donc on est
obligé de manger c'est déjà ça nous
coûte une tonne jeudi et après on voit
voilà votre sentiment
et après on lui dit où le laisse olive
asie voilà au lieu d'un petit billet
aller manger tous les deux c'est vrai
voilà et on le regarde de loin comme ça
et se casser la gueule
malfoy je me suis pris ça en même fois
je me suis retrouvé à faire des soirées
au départ on était 3 et après on se
retrouve seul face à face franck
gastambide et moi à regarder m'a dit
qu'au loin entre indochine et la botte
mais on adore et on laissera jamais
tomber ces eurobonds on est comme ça qu
on est en arrêt pour restaurer alors moi
je peux pas savoir le nombre de meuf qui
me disent est ce que tu connais malik
bentalha est ce qu'il pourra voir le
numéro de quelqu'un d'autre c'est ça
notre succès en ce moment c'est
incroyable arrête pas et je vous dis
physiquement vous monsieur sur le
tire-fesses de la bouée située sur la
charrette 3800 2200 il ya des soeurs
sportifs ou les arrête toi tu redescends
et m'a dit qu'il est comme ça dans la
vie c'est le même sans rigoler c'est
exactement le même
et voilà on a eu la chance de passer des
vacances ensemble et oui c'est vrai quoi
oui oui oui on a passé des vacances
semblent lui à chaque fois qu'ils
passent des vacances avec toi il se
passe des choses particulières ben tu as
fait des choses dans des baskets d'un
assez bon
et puis quand je suis revenue récemment
tu as préparé un match de tennis
ah ouais je me rappelle il a mis 24
heures à préparer un match de tennis je
pensais qu'il allait je vais pas faire
un match contre federer
on arrive le jour du match il joue
contre un gars de 14 en vacances avec
franck gastambide et malik bentalha et
on dit le soir j'ai ils veulent sortir
sinon les foires ya pas de resto n'ya
rien encore les jambes en l'air en train
de courir autour de la maison
au bout de deux au bout de deux points
contre lui il était en train d'insulter
un enfant les parents de l'enfant
ça va mal finir
ces radicaux tout cas dans l'aude où me
mettre en avant
malik bentalha qui est avec nous ce soir
malik tu as déjà fait on n'est pas
couché ou pas n'ont jamais non jamais
n'a jamais été invité ou t'as jamais été
non non m'a jamais invité à tirer non
non non je dirais pas un c'est vrai ça
ne chauffe pas captain awesome ça me
chauffe pas c'est juste que se
retrouvait face à il ya un gars qui
vient de bosser un album depuis depuis
deux ans et demi
ouais il arrivait il se fait démonter
par un mec jallet qui sait pas ce que
c'est un clavier quoi tu vois ça je
trouve ça un peu je critique pas mais je
trouve ça un peu bizarre qu'on peut
procéder vous julien vous l'avez déjà
fait on m'a jamais invité mais je suis
un peu dans le cas de ma vie que je
serais assez gêné je trouve que c'est un
peu un tribunal parfois d'accord donc ça
m'énervait